valero va profiter du changement de sens
vers l'est de la lune 9b du pipeline
d'enbridge prévu dans les prochaines
semaines jusqu'à 30000 tonnes de pétrole
en provenance de l'ouest devraient
arriver à montréal chaque jour une
grande partie continuera son chemin par
navire citerne jusqu'à la raffinerie de
lévis par ailleurs depuis juillet la
compagnie suncor achemine par train du
bitume dilué vers sorel tracy 4000
tonnes par jour c'est ce brut qui
commence tout juste à être exportées par
bateau principalement vers les états
unis
enfin si le projet de pipeline de
transcanada va de l'avant il aboutir à
un nouveau port en eau profonde à
cacouna en 2018
le pétrole sera surtout destiné à
l'étranger cent cinquante mille tonnes
chaque jour